everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
continuing our series on the Evans
gambit looking at part two we're going
to pick up right here at the Evans
gambit and after the Bishop takes on b4
and we move c3 he moves back to a5
common line we're going to be going over
another situation that black can do and
we move our pawn to d4 he captures and
we castle let's say this time he doesn't
want to take on c3 actually think for
black I would not recommend taking on c3
because White's going to get that
material back and at the same time he's
going to have Tim Poe as he develops his
pieces it's going to be pretty tough for
black in the long run I think from here
let's say black doesn't move like b6
putting his bishop in a much better
Square and at the same time defending
this pawn on d4 putting a lot of
pressure on the center after white
captures on d4 now black can play and
move like d6 and what it does a couple
things here this positions a little bit
different as it was before white now
Queen to b3 it's not going to be as
effective because now the knight can
come to a5 if you remember from the
first video this was not good for black
because after Knight excuse me Bishop to
f7 the King here when we moved our queen
to a4 and the King captured before we
could come and capture this knight on a
five but now as you can see this Bishop
on b6 is actually protecting this Knight
so Queen to b3 is not going to be our
best move
but it's good idea to know when there's
a good moving when it's not so you don't
always put your queen on b3 expecting it
to work out instead Knight to c3 simple
development move at the same time
controlling key squares controlling this
square on d5 and at the same time
controlling this pawn on e4 now from
here black would really like to Castle
kingside and he has two options first he
has to get his knight out of the way
we've already seen how Knight to h6 is a
bad move in the first video he has two
options he can bring his knight to e7
which seems logical he's putting another
defender on his knight on c6 they can
switch places if they need to if one
gets captured or his other one is Knight
to f6 the first one if you do see Knight
to e7 know that this is a mistake
because white can now bring his Knight
to g5 attacking this pawn on f7 they'll
move that black has to defend this city
moves castle from here white can bring
his Queen to h5 and this is going to
smell disaster for black the only way he
can defend this is if he tries his to
bring his pawn to h6
from here we can bring our Knight to f7
we're attacking this Queen if he gives
up his queen it's going to be a pretty
easy game for us as y'all can probably
tell let's say he tries to move his
Queen to e7 e e8 to get out of the way
we now have a discovered attack it's a
double check now any time a king is
double check he has to move his king it
doesn't matter which one he goes if he
goes to h7 or 88
let's just put them on h7 now we can
bring our knight back
his king is forced to move to g8 and now
it's simple checkmate so that's not
going to be good for black so E 7 is a
huge mistake if you see this make sure
that you take advantage of it instead of
e 7 though you may see Knight to f6 now
Knight to f6 we're going to do is we're
going to continue up the board with our
pawns pawn to e5 putting a lot of
pressure on black here we want to make
sure that black can not Castle kingside
if he takes he can't castle yet because
if he castles will just take his knight
that's not going to be good if he does
take with his pawn we're not going to
recapture it you always want to put
pressure on your opponent when you can
especially in the Evans gambit we're
giving up material in this opening to
put as much pressure as we can on our
opponents from here we're not going to
first take this instead we're going to
bring our bishop to a3 putting a lot of
pressure on King to Castle now if he
takes our pawn we can bring our rook to
e1 we're going to be putting as you can
tell even more and more pressure on the
black King black is going to have a
really hard time now to develop his King
side safety and as you can tell all of
our pieces now we can bring our Queen to
b3 as you can tell all of our pieces are
starting to work together and they're
all developed this is ample compensation
for the material advantage that black
has because white has Center control he
has great development and all his pieces
are aimed right at the King so this is
very good for white the other opening I
did want to talk about we've talked
about if the bishop moves back to a5 and
if he moves to e7 I also want to talk
about in the Evans gambit when he
captures
and our pond comes to c3 if he moves his
bishop back to c5 a lot of players that
aren't too familiar with the Evans
gambit is black you may see them play
this from here we're going to bring our
pawn to d4 if he now captures with his
pawn or attacking his bishop so I would
recommend that he takes with his pawn
now as bishop but we can bring our pawn
to d4 and his bishops now going to have
to move and you may see a similar
situation that you did before his if he
brings his bishop back to b6 but you can
tell after he moves his bishop he's
going to be losing time and development
we can Castle kingside we can now bring
our bishop queen into the action to b3
depending on where his bishop is we can
bring our Knight to c3
we have great Center control great
development and this is going to be very
good we're down one pawn and material
but as you can see this is a very
aggressive opening and we have ample
compensation for the pawn down so this
is the Evans gambit hopefully you guys
enjoyed if you do play the G oka piano I
highly recommend playing the Evans
gambit is it's very very good for white
and there's a lot of ideas that even if
it doesn't play out exactly like some of
these examples you can still have a lot
of very good attacking ideas from the
Evans gambit and have a lot of easy wins
against players that aren't too familiar
with it so hopefully you guys enjoyed if
you haven't already please subscribe
check out the website www.chesterlaw.com
and i will see you guys next video
thanks for watching everybody